josée legault michel david christian
dufour bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir un mot
sur paul st pierre plamondon qui
finalement a dit je n'irai pas dans
marie-victorin comme candidat du parti
québécois les cotons revient il ya des
risques de défaites puis des chances
très bonne de victoire une excellente
candidature ancrés localement et la
réalité c'est que j'ai pas d'ancrage et
que j'ai choisi ma circonscription déjà
mon nom le plein pour le suis puis moi
je continue le travail de terrain que je
m'étais engagé à faire qui est tellement
important
georges et qu'est ce qu'on doit en
passer
mais je pense que c'est la seule chose
qu'il a à faire c'est de ne pas pointer
dans ce piège comme ça de toute manière
les problèmes du parti québécois sont
nettement plus larges que ceux de me
suivre st pierre plamondon on n'a pas
besoin d'épervier longtemps là dessus et
quand il avait tenu son point de presse
vous vous souvenez où il avait dit j'ai
une stratégie pour marie victorine il
avait déjà fait allusion à la fois que
possibilité qu'il ait un candidat ou une
candidate de stature nationale bon et
c'est ce qu'il promet encore donc on
verra je dois vu dans même temps
c'est une circonscription qui paie 15
depuis croire 40 ans oui c'est un
château fort mais vous savez les notions
de châteaufort péquiste maintenant ça me
fait juste plus il ya aucun compte et au
québec la même parmi ceux que le pq à
l'emporter en 2018 qui peut être
considéré comme sûr
maintenant ceci étant dit monsieur st
pierre plamondon était bien fou de se
présenter là dedans la défaite et est
pratiquement assurée
évidemment le message que ça voilà le ou
la candidate qui va se présenter c'est
ta peau grâce à cissé le chef veut pas
se faire élire je comprends que ça peut
être un candidat ou une candidate comme
meilleur ancrage local mais il risque de
façon générale le parti le chef ça
compte beaucoup dans la zone campagne à
l'hectare alors bon monsieur st pierre
plamondon va devoir se magasinait notre
comté mais ça sera plus facile
a raconté où il dit avoir un ancrage
écouter mme st-pierre plamondon il est
de la région de montréal il y en a pas
beaucoup de comptes est prenable dans la
région de montréal ceci étant dit c'est
pas une obligation on a vu souvent des
chefs se présenter mais monsieur legault
a pas particulièrement d'ancrage dans
l'assomption
monsieur kouyaté exemple couillard à
roberval enfin oui les les exemples sont
multiples mais au total je pense c'était
la chose à faire mais est à peu près
tous les analystes politiques
vous entendez là dessus mais pour le
public en général christian qui regarde
ça donne quand même pas une image de ben
j'ai pas de perdre j'irai pas
et la politique ne s'est pas de la
morale il faut plus apolitiques intègre
des éléments moreau mais c'est une
dérive actuelle beaucoup de gens afin de
confondre les deux il se défile pas en
fait il pas masochiste pas suicidaire
quoi jusqu'à ce qu'on dit mes deux
collègues la politique c'est une espèce
de guerre civilisé encadré quand de tout
le choix de vos pas dans un combat que
toutes les chances de perdre je pense
qu'ils se réservent pour l'élection
générale explosif vous avez raison il ya
des gens qui vont dire il devrait y
aller parce que c'est depuis neuf mois
là dessus a brillé avec la douce du bois
qui le policier qui les égarements bayer
pas dans la noblesse et dans lequel
winston que pour respecter la tradition
de présenter deux adversaires
monsieur pour le sapeur d'abandon alors
que lui-même en avait profité de la
politique tout voulez vous c'est pas
juste de répondre à l' des beaux
sentiments c'est aussi en fait décidé de
régler des victoires serrées glisse h à
salle des on en a parlé cette semaine
encore c'était le témoignage de la
ministre mais cannes on va l'écouter on
n'a pas laissé passer pas filmer le
témoignage devant la carne mais elle a
fait un petit point de presse on écoute
il ya d'autres facteurs mais le manque
de gestionnaires rejoint rôle important
je n'étais pas au courant que il y avait
des gens qui avaient manqué de
nourriture et d'eau gelée su à un moment
donné parce que il ya dans des centres
hospitaliers un centre hospitalier un
médecin qui a fait part de cette réalité
tout ce passait tellement vide et encore
une fois
tout le monde a fait tout son possible
je commence avec vos michel c'est à
l'intérieur elle a montré du doigt plus
clairement les
responsables décès si les dirigeants des
six le dise tu es plus eux qui auraient
dû qui aurait dû savoir nous dira michel
oui j'ai trouvé cela nettement assez
désolant la façon dont madame mécano
renvoyer la balle aux dirigeants je suis
convaincu qu'ils ont une responsabilité
mais c'était elle qui était la ministre
est dans les détails de son témoignage
il ya des éléments troublants par
exemple le prétendu que à la veille une
réunion avec les
pdg à la fin janvier or il ya un avocat
qui a brandi un procès verbal que vous
écoutez madame il n'y a jamais été
question seuls les ch à celle des dans
cette réunion là ce que ça serait pas
plutôt à la fin février et la madame
makan avait pas vraiment d'explication à
un autre moment donné
c'était il s'agit d'un courriel que
des propriétaires du centre r us mais ça
va envoyer et voilà jamais vu le
courriel apparemment la dame s'était
trompé de bois tout ça était assez d
aller à mon sens changé
oui c'était triste et
je pense qu'un des gros problèmes il la
connaît roger en camel le soulever elle
même c'est justement cette contradiction
entre la version de l'ex ministre mais
kahn et de son ex ou minet souci vent
gendron les et horacio arruda les trois
ont dit que il était au courant qu'une
pandémie a mené dès la fin janvier dès
la fin janvier il avait demandé au pdg
d'eads et cissé desssus de préparer les
ch et celle d or comme le dit michel
l'avocat des familles ont montré un
procès verbal où c'était le 26 février
où il est écrit noir sur blanc que l'on
demande à la sécurité civile et au
ministère de la santé qui doivent être
dorénavant en mode préparatoire pour une
pandémie dorénavant le 26 février et moi
je me souviens très bien horacio arruda
qui à la fin du mois de janvier avec une
sortie vous vous en souviendrez sûrement
où il avait dénoncé l' épidémie de peurs
qui circulait
sur une sur une soi-disant par des mig
mais que tous les liens
web qu'il avait utilisé gros mots aussi
pour se moquer des gens qui avaient peur
donc est ce qu'on est en train de nous
dire qu'il savait tout à la fin janvier
mais qu'à la population horacio arruda
disait le contraire de plein de choses
là dedans on vient au même point ça va
prendre une vraie enquête christian
oui mais à qui aurait sûrement marche
qu'on s'en allait vers un tel cataclysme
en ce bien un mot l'onu vont être
réalisés avant une pandémie on avait une
idée un peu de ce que c'était mon
pouvais pas
prévoir je dors avec josé que soit une
vraie enquête il faudrait actuellement
on est très jovialisme québec par
rapport à la pandémie la gestion de la
pandémie on est content dé satisfaire au
moins cette enquête du coroner loeb nous
rappelle le déshonneur totale de notre
société dont le siège est celle des tous
ces gens là qui sont morts tout seul on
a empêché les proches d'aller les voir
ça reste seul et je crois que c'est ça
mérite man comme son enquête qu'est ce
qu'ils méritent nous comme si on est bon
là comme ça à la santé oms 9 e le
pré-rapport que quelque sorte si bon que
certains éléments mais mes romans je
trouve que ce n'est pas très très très
profond et quant à l'accord au maire
fait sale job
le coroner vous savez moi je l'expliqué
dans la sphère et chaque fois je
trouvais qu'elle était sortie de son
rôle parce que c'est un gars parler du
rachis systémique j'espère que ce maca
sorte de son rôle puis à 10 écouté il
faudrait avoir quelque chose de plus
large le plus structurelle regardez ce
qui s'est passé parce que sinon c'est un
peu trop facile de dire bon c'est de la
faute du gouvernement avant que c'est de
la faute des justes sa mère c'est de la
faute de tout le monde je pense qu'on a
une chance essayons d'en faire une
chance de ce grand malheur de se
regarder en face les québécois dans
l'eau structure chez que monsieur
legault est molle et comme son enquête
ne parlant grave après midi mais si un
dossier qui mérite une vraie comme si on
arrête de dire qu'est ce qui marche pas
dans le système public et parapublic
c'est beaucoup de clubs c'est à
dire parce qu'aujourd'hui on est trop
jovialiste est trop de bonne humeur je
trouvais québécois par rapport à sion
changer et oui c'est ce qu'on se disait
ici même
mardi donc je pense que plus les travaux
de la commission du coroner devrait dire
qu'un mais elles vont avancer plus les
contradictions des différents
témoignages vont sortir plus les
demandes pour une vraie comme si on
accueille public g6 publics vont monter
ça c'est également un petit tour de
table rapide avant de parler de hockey
sûr parce que ça sera confirmée demain
mais c'est confirmé tous les médias
l'ont là c'est la vaccination
le vaccin fin juin est approuvé par
santé canada sera l'annonceur fait
demain pour les 5 à 11 ans et là
monsieur legault a dit tout à l'heure
là c'est la dernière pièce avant début
2011 22 at il dit de laisser aller alors
ça sera une opération josé importante
quand même
oui
j'irai voir comment ça va fonctionner
aussi savoir considère on va voir mais
il reste d'autres morceaux aussi aux
poseurs et c'est la fameuse troisième
dose aussi du vaccin pour les personnes
qui ont eu leur deuxième dose ya au
moins six mois il ya de plus en plus de
pays qui ont ouvert cette troisième dose
la grande partie de leur population est
en hausse et les prix quarantaine de
sceller +50 ici c'est extrêmement
restreint et pourtant toutes les études
scientifiques nous démontre la
d'immunité commence à baisser après 6
mois donc il ya plein de vaccins que il
faut revisiter il faut retourner il ya
des rappels place et compte une pas des
mille donc ce morceau là je trouve qu'il
manque en ce moment rapidement michel et
christian sur l'opération qui va être
annoncé demain à prouver demain est
annoncée la semaine prochaine
c'est une excellente chose parce que là
on le voit actuellement ce sont les
jeunes qui sont les
les plus fins qui contractent le virus
le plus que les vecteurs et même s'ils
sont pas très malades eux mêmes ils
peuvent le transmettre alors en soit
c'est excellent je pense mais on va
avoir le même problème de non vaccinés
ce à dire que là on voit il ya eu déjà
des hoquets de départ acquis et je peux
pas les blâmer sont résistants à faire
vacciner leurs enfants est-ce que c'est
30% 40% 50% qui vont du mal à moi non
non je peux sauter puis alors il va y
avoir un problème
plus grave encore je pense que sont les
adultes christian notamment mais moi je
parle expertise sanitaire le plus
prononcé sur la version
d'un côté
je peux plus
rapidement
c'est juste hier en fait il y avait une
nouvelle qui sortit qui faisait que les
les enfants très jeunes avaient été très
très très traumatisée par la preuve il
est tout dire qu'il sortit je reprends
du salage le premier ministre et c'est
pas de blague le lac le 1er mai sont là
on en a parlé plus tôt diront ils
forment un comité avec beaucoup de monde
en disant d'ici havrais je veux des
recommandations
je veux faire renaître michel david le
hockey au québec alors vous le voyez tel
au centre bell il prend sa
relation publique ou réel effort de
changer des choses dans ce monde là qui
va pas si bien que ça se passe les
problèmes sont réels ils ont été exposés
plus tôt le avec vos interlocuteurs et
en a beaucoup et il sait pas simplement
parce que pas assez de québécois dans
les eaux nationales
il faut dire que le hockey n'a plus le
monopole
des adeptes de sports le soccer le ski
fond il ya beaucoup de choses qui est
qui ont remplacé le hockey pour beaucoup
de gens mais le timing évidemment pas
une question puis là il faut pas se
cacher dans une année électorale
toutes les décisions que prend un
gouvernement sont étudiés à partie en
fonction des échéances électorales alors
monsieur legault
cultive la fierté le rock est un objet
de fierté alors a pas besoin d'un dessin
devient compliqué pour comprendre que ça
pourrait être payant produits c'est josé
il fait vibrer toutes les cordes
sensibles
oui j'ai l'impression qu'il ya comme une
espèce de liste la 10e fête à l'avancé
toxico shiko shiko nique etc aussi
fierté que si une nationalisme
francophones
dans la ligue de hockey et c'est donc
moi je suis comme christian je suis pas
du tout une experte à qui ça qu'il parle
même pas cette langue là j'ai mal à
comprendre mais mais sur le plan
politique michel a tout à fait raison
c'est c'est clair c'est tout est mesuré
à l'aune de la prochaine élection comme
pour tout gouvernement sortant la
question est est ce que les décisions
qui sont prises ou les annonces qui sont
en fait vont d'un sens du bien commun
oui ou non ça va être au sein des
libellules critias
parce que j'aime bien françois legault
il ya des limites à vouloir avoir l'air
sympathique parce qu'on va donner on
frise la démagogie c'est promis de
québec il ya des problèmes très
importants
bon je coûtais c'est tout le monde aime
ce bon puis parler aussi de la langue
l'on parle à part par la banque je
trouve que des dossiers comme majeurs et
structurants comme l'imposition de la
loi 101 aux cégeps sont beaucoup plus
importantes que ces
manifestations lot de relations
publiques royaume et des sports dans
l'air sympathique mais voilà c'est dit
est-ce que c'est ouais c'est presque
terminé merci beaucoup à vous trois on
se laisse là dessus je vous demanderai
pas de devenir des experts en qui le
rassure et vous salue à bientôt et au
revoir merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit